[Music]
let's go to steve in dallas texas hey
steve what's up brother how can i help
hey how you doing appreciate you taking
the call thanks for calling brother
what's up man
um
so my question is
how can i not be so bitter at my job or
my my place of employment
how can you not be so bitter what are
they doing to you man they hitting you
with sticks and stuff what's happening
uh not not uh so much i've been there
about 15 years now and uh what do you do
i work at a uh at a plant
okay um
if you think homer simpson sit in front
of a computer and pushing buttons that's
what i do
so i i get why you're bitter
actually it is really a
it's a slow job but
you know it can be a good job
it's interesting
um that's what my wife says about me
like he's not very fast he just kind of
meanders around but he can be all right
but he's interesting
right that's right okay so
um
so why are you bitter man so i hired in
about 15 years ago
the last job i had i was in in
supervision it was a different field but
uh you know in my mind supervision is
supervision people are people
you manage people you learn the process
you manage the process
uh so
my train of thought was you know i've
done this for so long i'm gonna go and
you know start looking at that well
um
15 years
12 interviews later and uh
i'm still sitting in the same place that
i've been
day one
and again you know it can be a boring
job so you know
there is
it's just a lot of time sitting there
you know sometimes literally doing
nothing steve why won't they why won't
they promote you
hold on let me know let me ask that let
me change that question
um i asked you a bad question
what about you is not promotable after
15 years
so there's a couple of things
one i'm not without my faults i have i
have been known to make my opinion known
uh when maybe i should just get my mouth
shut
uh
i make my opinion known a lot here
um at where i work and
i work for dave ramsey who's an
opinionated guy
so i've heard yeah that's the rumor
right um
so having an opinion and letting it be
heard isn't the issue
what what is your actual issue are you a
jerk sometimes
i don't think so no
no i uh do you dig your heels in on
stuff like what uh yes but you know
there's times that that uh we have to
reasons etc
uh you know they even um
they uh
they promote that you know okay you
don't believe in this thing if there's a
problem with it it's up to you to stand
up say no
um but they're not promoting you though
and so there's a difference between what
they're saying they want and what you're
providing them
right
okay what what is that difference
i
i don't know i've done special projects
for them anytime i do a project i'm
always oh man that was great wonderful
you did an outstanding job
i hear great things
um
you know my first thought honestly is
i'm not in the clique
okay you know i don't i don't uh go out
drinking after work
i don't play golf on the weekends
um
well not after the weekends our
schedules rotating but
um
i you know i just
the things that a lot of those guys do
i don't do okay
and
so the currency at that job
are those things
and you have chosen to not participate
which i don't fault you at all okay you
have your own life you have kids
yeah okay so they have taken priority
and your wife's taking priority over
playing around on the weekends and
whatnot that's awesome man
and you happen to work at a place where
that's currency
or there's an illusion that that's
currency i don't always believe that it
is
but it might be
um when you're not getting invited to
those things you're not doing those
things it's easy to think that's the
currency but let's just pretend it is
um what else man you said you make your
opinions known what else
um
i you know that's
honestly that's you know about the only
two things i've been really honestly
come up with have you ever worked with a
boss who's a jerk
uh plenty yeah have you ever worked with
a boss he's just a loud mouth [ __ ]
yep
and they still had a promotion they were
still
um in leadership right
right so having it it's been my
experience that having a
loud opinion
doesn't keep you out of jobs
it's
a lack of social awareness when you
decide to do that it's people who gossip
it's people who whine as people who are
always complaining it's people who
that's the stuff that in my experience
of 20 years of hiring and firing a lot
of people
that has kept um and then when i
experienced that when i was whining and
complaining and whatnot and i didn't get
promoted
um
so i'll come back to you if you were the
boss why wouldn't you promote you
for 15 years
um
i i
you know i i've really had a loss i mean
i've thought it over um
i i've
dwelled on it so much it's it's
literally affected my health where i've
just had to say you know what i don't
care anymore
but you do but you do care though man
you do i do care you're right yeah you
do
but
you know i can't even get the uh
and this is you know actually it's just
it comes back from my original question
but i can't even get an answer from like
hr why you know give me some feedback on
the last promo or last interview i did i
did an interview in april
so two weeks after they made a decision
and i emailed the hr people and said hey
you know
give me some feedback why did i you know
what can i do better and it was a great
professional email it was you know nice
and
courteous and
you know what can i do better what do i
need to work on
well you know here it is the end of
august and
all i keep getting is oh i'm just so
busy i'll get back with you oh i'm just
so busy
i haven't forgot about you i'll get back
with you who's your who's your
supervisor who's your leader at the
company
uh
there's well see i work at one plant
that's owned by a corporation okay
and there's
uh you know i've probably got five
bosses within the plant
you know i mean stair step up but and so
after 15 years you don't have a
relationship with one of those people
one of those women or men that you could
say dude what's the deal man
um you know a couple of them i did and i
was kind of waiting on that hr because
i've i've worked with them in the past
uh others you know they just rotate them
around
often
so
a few years ago this is a couple
universities ago um
i thought i was a shoe-in for a big
promotion and i didn't get it and not
only did i not get it i didn't even get
an interview for it which was a signal
right
right that was a message that was sent
and
so i reached out
to a buddy who was a senior leader and
said dude what happened and
he said man i have no idea let me find
out and they did some digging around
and then he said i got some answers
let's go to lunch and dude it was a hard
lunch
and he told me here's your reputation
around here
and it was 100 opposite of the
reputation i wanted to have
and i didn't understand how i'd gotten
it
at first and then as i began to dig into
it i started to go
oh no right
and i had some major behavior changes
and some major soul searching to do
and
um i'd ask myself is this the the
group that i want to be associated with
longer term
right and ultimately i transitioned
myself out
so two things are
are
going on here i think number one
they have been sending you a message for
a long long time
and i don't think you want to hear it
and so i'll just be direct
they don't value you there
anything beyond what your day job is
and that's hard to hear because you've
given 15 years of your life to that
company
but they don't have any sort of
trajectory for you
they don't
right
right because either they would give you
a set of skills you could be working on
i've had hard conversations at every
place i've ever worked people have
pulled me in a room and said hey dude we
need this from you instead of that or
this isn't going to cut it we need this
and i love those because it's them
investing in me you're not getting that
right
but loud and clear they're saying we are
not investing in you and this is where
this is going to stop for you and so the
question you have to ask yourself is
this when it comes to bitterness right
because bitterness is this
is this gap between what we think we
deserve and what we're actually getting
right that's what bitterness is
yeah
you've got to ask yourself do i like
this job
does it pay well i've been trying for 15
years for something and it's not working
so starting today i'm gonna stop hitting
my head up against that wall because
i've tried that a bunch and it's not
working
am i at peace with being here and
clocking out and going home to be with
my four kids and my wife
or do i want to get back into leadership
at which point i'm going to have to
leave
and i'm not going to be angry with
anybody i'm not going to
not run this company down and be angry
at my get to my leaders and what
i'm just gonna start looking for
somewhere else to go
i'm gonna do that with joy in my heart
and peace in my heart does that make
sense
absolutely yeah anything beyond that is
a choice a for you to be miserable b
it's a choice for you to play revenge or
get back or whatever for something that
you really aren't owed
um
and then here's the second thing so
that's number one they're they're
communicating a lot and clear we don't
value you beyond where you value you
beyond where you are
the second thing here is
i don't think you really want to know
because i've been in your seat multiple
occasions through 20 years of
professional work man
and when i want to know
why i got passed up for a promotion i'll
go find out
i really want to know
even if it's uncomfortable for me
and so what i'm gonna come back to i've
asked this at the beginning and ask it
again
do you really really not know
why they're passing you up or do you
kind of know and you don't really want
to dig in and hear it
i mean it's it's
i i probably kind of know i probably
have a reputation because i was
uh because of things i brought up early
on
um
i don't know i i guess they didn't like
the way i brought it up maybe someone
got rubbed wrong i don't know
i mean like i'm generally a nice guy
i mean unless someone really rubs me
wrong but
so let me ask you this then okay
so if i if i say and you know i'm kind
of at the point where i'm just like you
know what i'm good right where i am okay
uh you know i'm not going for any more
promotions not to do it it's i'm gonna
stay right where i am
um this job pays very well yeah
uh it's union job union pension it's
it's uh very
it's worth sticking around i got 10 or
12 more years and i can walk out the
door
not necessarily a golden parachute but
it's gonna be really nice you'll be a
maid man there you go i will yeah
um
so you know
my question really is
how do i just let this go and say you
know what
if the pass the pass i'm just gonna move
forward because there are days they go
in there and say you know what
i don't even want to give you 100
and that is not about them
that's an integrity issue between steve
and steve
yeah
and any day you choose to not give a
hundred percent and each day you choose
to
go in there
halfway
is it you a a day that you don't cheat
that company
you're cheating yourself man
it's an integrity decision right and so
i i think that we
over
emphasize work uh i mean when i say work
um
over emphasize
um job description and title as a proxy
for self-worth i think we way over do it
in this in this culture i'd much rather
be considered a great great dad than a
vice president of a thing right now
providing a good a good living and i can
go spend time with my family all that
stuff's really important
um so if you are at peace with where you
are
then brother be at peace with where you
are and so what you're gonna need to do
is a couple of things number one you're
gonna need to have a hard conversation
with steve
that says i am completely at peace with
where i'm at
whatever i do at a given day i don't
know exactly ins and outs of your job i
deliver value to people on the other end
of this thing
and their life their day their whatever
is better because steve is in it you
have to have some sort of purpose in
your job
it could be providing levity and joy to
those who work around you to the
salesman that you work with for others i
don't know exactly what you do right but
it's about finding purpose where you're
at
the second thing is
you're gonna have to take your wife out
and apologize not apologize
but say i'm done complaining and whining
about my job for that i've done for 15
years
and for 15 years i've stayed here
because the money's good but i've just
been bitter i've just been frustrated
i've just been angry and i'm putting all
that to bed
and in fact i want you to call me on it
when you when you hear me starting to
bring it up again
just touch my arm just just reach your
hand out and touch my hand you're gonna
have to practice is what i'm telling you
steve okay and having your wife um to
hold you accountable
is gonna be important and then if you've
just been complaining and whining about
your job in front of your kids tell them
bring them in and say guys i haven't
handled this the right way i'm sorry
i've been trying to get stuff and i've
been bitter and frustrated and i'm gonna
put that down
i'm gonna go in i do a good job i'm paid
a fair wage and i wanted to be a leader
and i don't even want to do that anymore
i'm grateful for the time i get to spend
with you guys
and then when you are off
when you go to work and you have those
days where there is nothing for you to
do you can find things either to reach
out to your supervisor and your leader
and say hey man how can i
finish all my work today anything else
any other projects i can lean into or a
co-worker how can i help or if it's not
one of those kind of jobs it's the kind
of job where you just sit and do nothing
literally
then take that time of self-improvement
time take an online course get an
associate's degree in something for free
they got free community college there in
dallas get a book and start reading get
a couple of guys at work that do the
same stuff as you and start a book club
where y'all reading stuff together
begin writing your wife letters every
day at work and tell her how wonderful
she is i don't care what they are but
use that choose to use that time
productively
instead of just sitting there in that
gap between what you think you're
entitled to and what's actually
happening in reality
if after 15 years of being scorned of
not getting promotion and here's the
thing i'm not mad they didn't promote
you i do think it's lame
that a they kept you around for 15 years
and haven't been honest with you unless
they have and you just didn't want to
hear it but b you ask for feedback and
they're not giving it to you that sucks
that's lame
any business owner out there if somebody
comes and says hey man how can i get
better have the courage to be honest
with them even if it's a hard hard hard
conversation
that's the part i don't like steve is
that they're not treating you with
integrity they're not being honest with
you about what you can do better next
time or how you can grow as an employee
or how you can grow fill in the blank
they're not even being honest with you
and saying
management will not be in the cards for
you here period we love what you're
doing for us and we love the role you
are in you will not be a leader at this
facility
i wish they'd they would tell you that
then you could mourn it and move on with
your day they're not doing that right
at the end of the day
you walking in every day with a set of
affirmations that said here's the kind
of man i'm gonna be when i get to work
i'm gonna be someone who's got purpose
who tries to make other people's day
better i'm gonna do my job with
excellence i'm gonna let my wife and
kids know that i'm grateful for the job
i have and for i'm gonna put in the hard
work and then when i have a gap in time
i'm gonna invest in steve to get more
skills to learn things to
start hobbies whatever the thing is is
gonna be
and when you feel that resentment and
that bitterness
rise up
you catch it you go for a walk you
breathe it out
sometimes i'll find myself and i'll just
have you heard me say it on the show
i'll say nope not going there and i'm
going to stop that um that thought cycle
i'm not going to get on the road they
didn't ask me to be a part of that team
i'm not going to be i'm not on that team
do i think i should been on it yep and
that's the last conversation i'm going
to have with myself about that today i'm
going to put an end to it if you begin
to practice this over time that default
setting will shift i promise you you
gotta be intentional about it you gotta
bring other people in on this deal you
gotta be apologetic and say i'm moving
on from the past
but you can get there be graceful with
yourself as you practice it you've been
whining and complaining and frustrated
for 15 years it's not going to change
overnight
but you will be become a more joyful
person to be around you'll become a
somebody that people flock to when it
comes to and by the way
start an exercise program at home
ask your wife if after 15 years she
wants to go to marriage counseling and
wants to
recreate your marriage into something
really powerful and fun and exciting
pick up fishing um begin to do things
that are about moving your body about
growing your heart growing your mind and
separate yourself from this identity
anchor you've given yourself which is i
need to be a leader i have before leader
leadership is leadership i've done it
before i can do it again well not here
you can't okay
i think you're a person worth growing
steve and right now your company's not
investing in it so you can
and choose
joy
thanks for the call brother